[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much i appreciate it um
i would like to talk a little bit about
the changes in america that have
occurred over the last two and a half
years obviously everybody's gone through
this pandemic but it's what it's done to
the economy that matters
and at the end of the day it's one of
the reasons i'm here because let's just
start with the environment there's a
really really interesting competition
starting between states in america today
now maybe it's because of the pandemic
maybe it's because the economy went
digital maybe it's because it's just
starting to occur to businesses that
there are some states
that are pro-business
and there are others that are not
now very often
entrepreneurs are nervous about
calling out a state for being bad at
promoting business or having over
abusive regulation or not having policy
from a tax perspective that makes sense
well i'm not scared of doing that
new york
terrible for business
new jersey terrible for business
massachusetts horrifically terrible for
business
california is not in business
now i say that because i have to make
investment decisions all the time and
i'm trying to find places to put capital
to work there's a reason the price of
real estate in miami has gone up
40 percent in 18 months it's because
everybody that's managing capital in new
york and new jersey and massachusetts
has moved to miami and they count their
days and this is a healthy competition
between states
this is good this is good for america
there are good managers
and there are bad managers and there's
nothing wrong with calling them out
now let's talk about what drives the
economy today
number one
clearly what happened during the
pandemic digitized the economy forever
it's very easy to understand what
happened let's make it really basic most
people couldn't leave to go get their
groceries for almost 18 months without
putting a mask on or if you're an
elderly citizen maybe never getting out
because you're worried about getting
covert maybe you didn't know how to use
your phone to order groceries
well you do now
you definitely know how to do it no
question about it
you figured out all the things that you
can do
digitally
now that's fantastic there's no question
about it and i'll tell you why
prior to the pandemic i was an investor
in 34 separate private companies in
almost every state
we were in everything very diverse
insecticide
gym equipment greeting cards commercial
kitchens cupcake distribution you name
it
wireless charging
and that portfolio of private companies
was making about 15
pre-tax and that by the way is running
on all
systems that's fantastic
and you know 66 of our economy are
private businesses 50 to 500 million in
sales that is the essence of america it
is the entrepreneur maybe it was the
grandfather to start the business maybe
it's the first generation right now but
it's that individual with the fire in
their belly that wants to be independent
and free that starts a business and
that's the kind of entrepreneur that i
support because it's good business
they're all over america they're
everywhere
when the pandemic hit
their traditional forms of distribution
and i'll give you a pie chart of what
consumer goods and services looked like
pre-pandemic
50
of sales
went through retail your targets your
bed bath and beyond your walmarts and
that's 50 cents on the dollar that's
good business they've got massive
distribution
they have dc's everywhere people go to
these stores to buy things
and you make 50 cents on the dollar by
the time you take all your costs into
account
40 percent of sales of most of these
companies
went through amazon
which is the largest retailer in the
world
more or less direct to consumers but not
your consumers because they make you
give up the right to your consumer data
which is okay trade-off to make 60 cents
on the dollar and prior to the pandemic
these companies made 10 percent on their
own their own websites direct to
consumer so they had their own data so
if you're selling sneakers like a nike
pre pandemic and you are about 38 direct
consumer today around the world that s p
company is well over 50 percent direct
consumer and is no longer reliant on
retailers
size
color preference when these sneakers are
purchased all that data floating in the
cloud making the company very powerful
in its ability to direct its capital to
the right countries for the right sizes
the right styles
that's what you do with information like
that i don't care if you're a 50 million
dollar company a 500 million or a 50
billion dollar company this data is
valuable
i said data
it's very valuable in fact data drives
the entire
economy every single sector of the s p
500 there are 11 sectors
of the s p 500 energy is a sector
technology is the sector consumer is a
sector
every single one of them is driven by
data and every day the demand for data
is more and more insatiable
think about a tesla car
it's a computer on four wheels reporting
back to the mothership every inch it
moves
data think about a drone flying over the
skies of montana looking at forests
terabyte of data think about the
military
exploring and working with other
countries data think about the tax that
you pay data driver's license data
amazon data microsoft data google data
data data data data data that's what it
is it's the new
oil
that's what data is more valuable than
anything else
very important now
where do you put the data where do you
store the data
what has occurred in the last few months
in the ukraine this horrific outcome
that's occurred there has woken up every
sovereign in the world
not to just war and invasion
but about data
where do you want your data if you live
in montana where do you want your data
you want it sitting in ukraine
where a russian tank rolls over the data
center i don't think so
do you want it in a foreign country no
you want it right on the sovereign soil
where it's created every single state
every canadian province every mexican
province every swiss canton
all of these countries are now realizing
the value of data and where is it stored
where is it sovereign where is it
protected where is it safe
data data data
now
to store data you need a data center
i don't care if you're in crypto
currencies or you're doing taxes or
you're tesla you're microsoft you're
google you're an advertiser it doesn't
matter you need a data center
data centers require semiconductors
very hard to get
but in the last 18 months there's
something else they require
they need clean
power
the world has decided for good or bad
whether you agree with it or you don't
that esg
really really matters
and companies that don't abide by a
greener future are being punished very
harshly in the stock market and i'll
give you a good example
prior to the esg mandate put forward
by blackrock larry finkett blackrock
came out with a letter 36 months ago
saying we're the largest money manager
on earth and i want to go green and
companies that don't agree with me
well they're not going to be part of our
mandate
that was a hell of a message
people thought he was kidding well he
wasn't then the sec just three months
ago put out a memo
saying that they decided that maybe they
should audit
carbon emissions in addition to the
financial statements the ceo the cfo and
the board has to sign
the statements and they've got to find
an auditor
to sign the statements because people
started to use what are called carbon
offsets
carbon credits
well
in that memo
the scc
called them out as bs you can't run
around saying you bought an acre of the
amazon forest and mine coal and say that
you're green
that's not going to work for the sec
according to this memo and the way you
could measure the effect of that was all
of the public companies on nasdaq and
new york stock exchange that were mining
bitcoin that were trading in proxy to
bitcoin pricing which is the granddaddy
of all cryptocurrencies their stocks got
crushed
down 50 60 70 80 95 when that memo came
out because they all use carbon credits
they tie to the grid
they burn coal they're dirty bitcoin
miners
and they no longer
have much of a market cap anymore
because not this is law this is the
perception of investors institutional
investors individual investors so
whether you agree with this or not
it is changing the direction of capital
now i work in the indexing business
indexers like me work with sovereign
wealth funds and i'll give you an
example let's say you're an oil rich
middle east country making 250 million
us dollars a day
the only place you can put that money to
work is in the s p 500 but they don't
want to buy more oil because they got
enough oil so they go to an indexer like
me and say look index the s p x airlines
x oil and we get paid for it and there's
lots of us doing it and we're happy to
do it
but they're trying to put so much money
to work every day and there's lots of
countries like that people think as us
as individual investors that we really
move the market
we're nothing burgers all of the wealth
in the world is in sovereign and pension
plans a lot of it's in america a lot of
it's in norway a lot of it's in the
middle east it's 95 percent of the
market so when you start thinking about
data data centers semiconductors
you've got to solve for a lot of
problems and clean power
you build a data center you're going to
pay about 2 million bucks a megawatt a
good data center is 300 megawatts that's
600 million smackaroos in the ground
you're not going to put that anywhere
where the environment's unstable or they
don't like business and i'll give you a
good example i had a project in upstate
new york right beside niagara falls lots
of hydroelectricity 100 percent
green
100 no need for an carbon audit because
there's no carbon
imagine water spilling over a dam
not being used you can use it to build a
data center what a great idea
new york doesn't like business
they basically put a bill in place
saying we're going to make this illegal
we don't want these data centers
capital stopped flowing there we move
that facility where
to norway why
they like business in norway they want
data centers they have tons of water
and we're building that 300 megawatts in
norway right now
i call it the norway model because not
only does the government like us
they like the fact that we have
investors they're solving wealth funds
that have access to semiconductors they
like the fact that we are in partnership
with the mayor of that town in northern
norway that the heat off the computers
can actually grow tomatoes with a
canning plant we built and we provide
the data centers to universities so they
can process information as well
now where else can we do that in the
world
where else can we find
leadership that likes business doesn't
hate it that wants to attract it that
has policy that's competitive
that has
water and hydroelectricity
that maybe the leadership actually ran a
business once that they actually made
payroll in their lifetimes that they
understand what that takes and how hard
it is to do
well where is
that right here in montana
right here now you've heard lots about
florida and lots about texas
yes
those states are attracting billions of
dollars of capital because the
leadership there gets the joke
they want business
and if i sound a little agitated about
this i am i can't understand why any
politician would chase away business the
essence and the heartbeat of america is
its economy a good strong economy great
job solves all problems that's how it
works you start with your economy you
make it work that way
but unfortunately here
many of our politicians
have never run a business
they've never run
anything where payroll is required on a
thursday by midnight they've never read
a balance sheet
they simply don't care
and that's why this great competition is
starting
and in the great way of entrepreneurs
funds flow to the path of least
resistance
the dollar bill doesn't vote
it only looks to where it can get a good
return with the least risk
it's not political it's really smart
and it knows where to go
well
it's coming here to montana
good leadership in both the senator and
the governor these guys have run
businesses you just have to meet them
and understand they know how to read a
balance sheet
they know that that matters and there's
all kinds of companies figuring it out
lifestyle is amazing here it's a
beautiful place
the internet doesn't care where you're
located anymore you can talk to anybody
in the world anywhere anytime
but when it comes to a data center which
is the reason i'm here
we care about where we build it
we care about the power source and we
care about the stability of the
environment
we want policy that we can see at least
seven years ahead
because when you spend that much money
you need time to get your returns and
make sure investors are happy and
provide services to all the customers
you're going to have
now we have this amazing digital economy
emerging
lots of controversy about bitcoin mining
lots of controversy about stable coins
but i'm here to tell you to think about
it this way
this is a neason sector data centers
serve everybody doesn't matter what
sector you're in bitcoin miners need
them the digital services need them
credit card companies need them it
doesn't matter what matters in a data
center is the source of energy and the
stability of the policy in the tax
regime
and the permits that you need to
maintain the business
the demand for these centers is
insatiable all around the world and the
states that have figured this out that
have good policy have wind have hydro
have solar
have nuclear power
have turbines and dams this is the
future
not here just not here but everywhere
but to the extent that we can put them
in states like this
we'll build them and i'm one of the
people here to tell you that
now
i've made this about 40 percent of my
efforts as an investor because the way i
look at this whole digital data center
thing
let's go back a couple hundred years to
the gold rush
people were crossing these lands and
looking for places to get their picks
and shuffles out and start digging for
gold it turned out the best investor
didn't go after the gold they provided
the picks and shovels and jeans to
everybody
well that's what a data center is you're
agnostic to who uses it you just have to
build a good one and have great
technology and low cost power and
maintain the semiconductor services so
that they're very very very best you can
give anybody and that's what we're going
to be doing here in montana i have a
very special announcement to make i'm
using this venue as an opportunity i'm
going to invite some people to the stage
here um
by the way i really like this place this
is not my first time here but i
certainly got the joke on why people
would move here it's a little piece of
paradise
and by the way that yellow show that
yellowstone show didn't hurt either
my goodness my wife and i binge watched
that thing you know i want to stay an
extra day just so i can go see where
they shoot it and by the way if the
producers are in here i want to be in
the show as a bad guy okay
all right i've got the the ceo of bit
zero that's the company i've invested in
akbar right over there you can hear from
him in a minute um i've got secretary
martin
i want to get his name right
charlo right
thank you
um
of course governor
he's here fantastic and of course the
senator i met the senator
steve in washington at a session we had
bipartisan about bitcoin he called me
his office and said why aren't you
looking at montana
this guy
both of these governor and senator these
guys are the best salesman this state
has i sat down with him i listened to
his pitch and said i'm in where do i go
here i am with a huge announcement
so
akbar are you going to come and tell us
what we're about to do here i'll let the
ceo do it i'd love to do it but you got
to listen to this guy
um
thank you kevin for all those wise
remarks and uh pleasure to meet everyone
i'll i'll keep it brief uh conscious of
everyone's time
um
i'm delighted to announce that bit zero
will be bringing uh world leading zero
carbon displacement data center
technology to montana
very much a function of the pace and
efficiency with which the state
leadership and the first nations
leadership were put on the table for us
with open hearts to hear and understand
how this business will unfold
we will keep sharing details as that
keeps happening
and i will give
martin the mic
thank you
[Applause]
all right thank you all uh my name is
martin sharlow i'm the tribal council
secretary for the confederate station
kootenai tribes um i live in the pablo
district
our tribes have always been a people a
vision and i believe that kevin and
mr daines and governor jim forte and
akbar
are all bringing
this great vision to us
we're looking forward to the opportunity
with the the summit um for you all to
kind of get to know us a little bit
better we have one of our corporations
here today um mr chad codd is here um
i'll embarrass him and put them out
there but i just want to make sure that
we are um
really excited to have clean renewable
um
and and energy that can grow uh
sustainable food for our nation and so i
just want to thank you kevin for the
opportunity and mr gianforte i'll turn
it over to you thank you
well let me let me start uh mr wonderful
thank you for coming to montana we kevin
we had a conversation in the capitol he
said i you said i want clean power
i said well you should go talk to the
salish and kootenai tribe because they
have cur dam
and
and we have a regulatory climate where
we can build these data centers
akbar appreciate your vision and
willingness to invest here in montana
it's going to create good jobs there
in
polson
with the building of this data center
using the clean power coming off the
flathead river and it's just
the tip of the iceberg i think there's a
lot more opportunity we appreciate your
confidence in us
and uh
we look forward to continuing to work
together so thank you so much for your
investment here
senator danes
[Applause]
so we're glad you didn't go to norway on
this project
in fact there were a lot of norwegians
that came to montana i'm sure if i asked
for a show of hands you talk about your
heritage that's my heritage in montana
in fact was a great great grandmother
who came from norway to minnesota and
heard the skiing was better in montana
and she homesteaded north of great falls
so my roots are norwegian we're glad to
see
important step going forward here we've
been blessed in montana as a headwater
state
where that snow
in the mountains that we ski on
then turns into water that irrigates
that we fish on
and it also is a tremendous source of
energy here in montana and hydropower
and we're grateful that we can play an
important part here in this digitization
of the the brave new economy going
forward
and that uh uh kevin and akbar you and
the sailors kootenai tribe are working
together here to do a really great thing
uh for the people of montana so thank
you
[Applause]
so i'll be coming back soon and uh
thanks for your hospitality here
it's been great working with you and how
how fast it happened so for all of you
looking at this state
stuff gets done fast here
i really like that
that's that's really good because you
can get to these guys sit down with them
and work it out and they'll guide you in
the right direction i can't say enough
good things i do this all around the
world i don't think we've ever done it
faster than this this is fantastic if
you like that video wait did you see my
next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe